secretly filmed inside London's Ritz
Hotel this is the moment Alistair
Barclay the nephew of billionaire
businessman Sir Frederick Bartley is
seen handling a covert listening device
release by Sir Frederick's lawyers it is
key evidence in a bitter high court
battle between the 85 year-old and
members of his brother's family over
allegations of commercial espionage on a
vast scale Sir Frederick and his
daughter Amanda are suing Sir David
Barclays three sons Alistair Eden and
Howard along with Eden's son Andrew and
Philip Peters a company director for
invasion of privacy breach of confidence
and data protection laws Sir Frederick
and Amanda alleged that the defendants
recorded more than 1,000 private
conversations and used the recordings to
commercial advantage at the heart of the
legal cases the sale of this
world-famous hotel owned by the Barclays
brothers until March when according to
Sir Frederick's lawyers it was sold by
the defendants to a Qatari businessman
for half its market volume aha this is
quite a simple claim this is a claim
that the children of Sir David Barclay
breached the privacy of Sir Frederick
Barclay
this isn't John dice and John dice
something out of Dickens its Barclay
against Barclay its Frederick Barclay
suing the children of his brother for
allegedly invading his privacy among
their business interest the berkeley
brothers on the Telegraph Media Group
they're deeply private their knighthood
at Buckingham Palace twenty years ago
one of the very few occasions they've
been publicly photographed during my
three years the city executive in
Scotland the barclay brothers struck me
as being intensely private man in fact
throughout that time it's both definite
ER and then the editor of The Scotsman
the only time I ever saw them was when
they attended the Royal opening of the
Scott
new building at Holyrood net in barra
when the Queen came to visit so I think
they will be absolutely horrified by the
exposure of their private life in this
way in this court case at an earlier
hearing lawyers for the defendants said
events here at the Ritz formed part of a
family dispute and that it's unfortunate
issues are being canvassed in public
rather than being resolved within the
family a trial date is yet to be set for
this case and what will be a rare
insight into the lives and business
dealings of a normally very private
family mark white Sky News